après la sortie des états unis de
l'accord de paris pendant le mandat de
donald trump ce sommet marque le retour
du pays en première ligne dans la lutte
contre le changement climatique seront
suivies de près les discussions avec un
invité très attendu mettant fin à un
certain suspense
la chine l'un des premiers émetteurs
mondiaux de gaz à effet de serre avec
les américains a annoncé sa
participation au sommet malgré de vives
tensions avec washington le président
chinois xi jingping devrait même
prononcé un important discours lors de
la rencontre
si l'entente entre les deux pays est
jugée cruciale pour la réussite des
efforts climatiques internationaux la
coopération devrait ici se formaliser du
côté de la russie qui est également de
la partie
les choses se précisent le pays est
souvent présenté comme étant en retrait
des négociations sur le climat
vladimir poutine se dit investi nous
devons relever les défis du changement
climatique
adapter l'agriculture l'industrie le
logement et les services communaux toute
l'infrastructure
il faut créer une industrie pour le
recyclage des émissions de carbone
parvenir à une réduction de leur volume
introduire un contrôle et une
surveillance stricte
le volume cumulé d'émissions nettes de
gaz à effet de serre de la russie
devrait passer en dessous de celui de
l'union européenne
l'union européenne devrait faire bonne
figure après l'adoption in extremis d'un
accord dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi
accord portant sur une réduction nette
d'au moins 55% de ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2030 par rapport à
1990 la confiance est de mise
les états unis ne nous sont pas
supérieurs sur le climat nous sommes le
grand frère ou la bande soeurs nous
pouvons les encourager ils seront
réellement poussé par nos actions ils
devront réagir lorsqu'ils verront ce que
nous avons accompli en invitant
l'ensemble des grands émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre les états unis veulent
inciter leurs partenaires à mettre en
oeuvre davantage de mesures concrètes
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique mais pourrait parvenir ils
devront lors de ce sommet affiché eux
mêmes des ambitions plus élevées